rak magera conte les aventures de
pistolets et de myrtilles l'unique
survivante du troupeau transformer
malencontreusement en brebis dragon par
la fée pompe est une fable bien déjanté
scénarisé par l'auteur des dieux
fourneaux wilfrid lupano
oui on m'avait m'avait cité la ville à
la fée clochette de loisel elle m'avait
dit on quand même la fée clochette de
loisel c'est une sacrée fait donc
faudrait il faudrait s'en inspirer mais
en faire une version plus destroy une
petite fée assez gironde assez sexy mais
porté sur la bouteille
il faut dire que l'homme n'a pas son
pareil pour dessiner des expressions
faciales
ici le sourire voluptueux d'éventuels la
l'oeil maussade du chanteur d'eurostat
tout ou encore les redonner de pistolet
ristolas j'aime mais j'aime bien aussi
j'aime beaucoup parce qu'il est il est
d'humeur plus égal mais il a quand même
c'est le caractère et puis peut être
assez coire par moments et puis et puis
c'est un brave type donc non il est très
agréable à dessiner pistolet puis il a
un physique un peu ingrat donc ça c'est
sympa pour un dessinateur
la jupe au crayon on est sûr de
l'ancrage et
un peu à la crème de traître est
hachurée l'idée c'était c'était d'avoir
un côté gravure un petit peu puisque ça
se passe dans un grimoire don valley que
ce soit vraiment à l'ancienne et je me
suis fait plaisir là on est dans du bon
du très détaillée terriblement drôle
toujours aussi rock'n'roll un peu moins
trash certes dire l'homme même pour
illustrer de l'heroic fantasy tu gardes
toujours ce côté cynique
ouais bah ouais c'est vrai si j'ai envie
de raconter l'histoire d'un petit chien
sympa et tout au bout de trois pages
j'ai envie qu'ils se fassent écraser et
du coup ça j'ai du mal à me sortir de
l'humour noir
oui l'oiseau bleu c'est toi lui c'est
spectralex dans l'oiseau bleu il jouera
en plein air à bléré à l'occasion de
jour de fête un festival de rue
entièrement gratuit ce sera les 20 et 21
septembre prochains
django 53 avec sébastien giniaux à la
guitare le quartet se produira jeudi
prochain dans le cadre du festival de
jazz de mont louis
mais
l'invention de la nature et l humilier
de l'homme ou bien l'homme est-il
l'invention de la nature phase
christophe gonnet ou encore yannick v au
total une cinquantaine d'artistes d'art
contemporain pour vingt lieux différents
la biennale de soleil ça durera jusqu'au
20 septembre
et puis de l'électro une voix hypnotique
celle de verveine
non
c'est
je
quand tu vois
comme moins
ce sera samedi 19 septembre à
l'astrolabe
une
santé - de nous
ça y est
je